we know this microbiome this magical mix
of bacteria is doing all kinds of jobs
in our bodies and there's very clear
evidence that for example whether a
particular medicine you take works well
or poorly whether you get side effects
or not has to do with whether these
microbiome bacteria are metabolizing it
or not and so the idea that you could
exploit that treasure trove of bacteria
if you learned enough about it to help
us make medicines that we have worked
better maybe make DPO work or maybe make
the medicines themselves right and I
think that is a huge dream in
microbiology right the idea that these
bacteria that live naturally in our guts
right they just haven't been asked to do
the right jobs yet but we could nudge
them right and that would be a super
interesting way to think about
personalized medicine like bonny
bastards microbiome does something good
for Bonnie Bassler
and your microbiome does something good
for you
you